les chercheurs en vision artificielle pensaient
que faire différencier à l'ordinateur un chat d'un chien
relevait presque de l'impossible,
et ce malgré les nets progrès réalisés en intelligence artificielle.
Nous y parvenons dorénavant avec une fiabilité supérieure à 99 %.
C'est appelé la classification d'images.
On prend une image, qu'on étiquette...
L'ordinateur connaît également des milliers d'autres catégories.
Je suis diplômé et j'étudie à l'université de Washington,
et je travaille sur le projet Darknet,
une structure en réseau neuronal
pour entraîner et tester les modèles numériques de vision.
Voyons ce que Darknet pense
de cette image.
Si nous analysons cette image
à l'aide du classifieur
nous obtenons la prédiction « chat » ou « chien »
mais aussi la race spécifique.
Voici le niveau de granularité actuel.
Et c'est exact.
Mon chien est un malamute.
Nos avancées en classification d'images sont donc incroyables.
Mais que se passe-t-il si notre classifieur
analyse une image de ce genre ?
Eh bien...
Il fournit une prédiction relativement similaire.
Et c'est exact, l'image contient un malamute.
Mais cette information n'indique pas grand-chose
sur ce qui se passe dans l'image.
Il faudrait aller plus loin.
Je travaille sur la détection d'objets.
Il s'agit de trouver tous les objets présents sur une image,
de les circonscrire
et de les identifier.
Voyons ce qui se passe quand le détecteur analyse cette image.
Ce genre de résultats démultiplient
les capacités de nos algorithmes de vision artificielle.
On voit qu'il a reconnu la présence du chat et du chien.
Il sait où chacun se situe
et leur taille.
Il peut même savoir d'autres choses.
Un livre se trouve au fond.
Si l'on veut concevoir un système basé sur la vision artificielle,
tel un véhicule autoguidé ou un système robotisé,
on recherche ce genre d'informations.
On cherche à pourvoir interagir avec le monde physique.
Quand j'ai débuté dans la détection d'objets,
il fallait 20 secondes pour analyser une seule image.
Pour que vous saisissiez l'importance de la rapidité dans ce domaine,
voici un exemple de détecteur d'objets
qui analyse une image en deux secondes
soit dix fois plus rapidement
que celui à 20 secondes par image.
On voit que le temps qu'il fasse des prédictions,
l'état des choses a changé,
et son application
serait peu utile.
En l'accélérant encore d'un facteur de dix,
le détecteur analyse cinq images par seconde.
C'est bien mieux.
Par contre,
si un mouvement important se produit,
je ne veux pas que ce système conduise ma voiture.
Voici notre système de détection en temps réel sur mon PC portable.
Il suit aisément mes déplacements dans le cadre,
il supporte une grande variété de changements de taille,
de postures,
si j'avance, recule.
C'est formidable.
C'est ce qu'il nous faut réellement
pour concevoir des systèmes basés sur la vision artificielle.
(Applaudissements)
En quelques années seulement,
on est passés de 20 secondes par image
à 20 millisecondes par image. Mille fois plus vite.
Comment avons-nous fait ?
Avant, les systèmes de détection d'objets
prenaient une image similaire
et la découpaient en zones,
puis un classifieur analysait chacune d'elles,
et on considérait qu'il était performant
s'il détectait des objets.
Mais ça signifiait analyser une image des milliers de fois
autant d'évaluations en réseau neuronal pour une détection.
On a alors entraîné un réseau unique à réaliser ces détections.
Il produit les délimitations et les probabilités de classes simultanément.
Notre système n'observe plus une image des milliers de fois
afin de réaliser une détection
mais une fois seulement.
D'où la méthode de détection YOLO pour « You Only Look Once ».
Cette rapidité ne nous limite plus aux seules images
et nous pouvons analyser des vidéos en temps réel.
Et au lieu de voir un chat et un chien,
on les voit se déplacer et interagir.
Nous avons entraîné ce détecteur
sur 80 classes différentes
de la base COCO de Microsoft.
Elle contient un peu de tout, de la cuillère à la fourchette et au bol.
Ce genre d'objets usuels.
Elle contient diverses choses plus inhabituelles :
des animaux, des voitures, des zèbres, des girafes.
Faisons une chose amusante.
Parcourons le public
et voyons le genre d'objets détectés.
Quelqu'un veut-il une peluche ?
Il y a des ours en peluche ici.
Repoussons un peu notre seuil de détection
afin d'en trouver plus dans le public.
Voyons si on trouve ces panneaux.
On a des sacs à dos.
Zoomons juste un peu.
C'est formidable.
L'analyse entière se déroule en temps réel
sur l'ordinateur.
Il faut garder à l'esprit
qu'il s'agit d'un système de détection d'objets à usage général.
On peut donc l'entraîner pour tout domaine visuel.
Le même code employé
pour détecter des panneaux stop, des piétons
ou des vélos par un véhicule autoguidé
peut être employé pour détecter des cellules cancéreuses
dans une biopsie.
Dans le monde, des chercheurs utilisent déjà cette technologie
pour progresser dans des domaines comme la médecine ou la robotique.
Ce matin, j'ai lu un article
qui traitait d'un recensement de la faune du parc national de Nairobi
qui utilisait YOLO pour son système de détection.
Cela est possible car Darknet est en open source
et dans le domaine public. Il est libre d'utilisation.
(Applaudissements)
On a voulu rendre la détection encore plus accessible et pratique.
Grâce à la combinaison de l'optimisation de modèles
la binarisation du réseau et l'approximation,
on peut utiliser la détection d'objets sur un téléphone.
(Applaudissements)
Je suis ravi, car nous disposons dorénavant d'une solution puissante
pour ce problème de vision artificielle faible.
Il peut servir à quiconque pour concevoir ce qu'il veut.
Pour le reste, à vous de jouer
ainsi qu'à ceux dans le monde qui ont accès à ce logiciel.
J'ai hâte de voir ce que les gens feront de cette technologie.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)